use graphing to solve the following
problem Abby and Ben did house abby
invented household chores last weekend
together they earned $50 and Abby earned
$10 more than Ben how much did they each
earn so let's define some variables here
let's let let's let a equal Abby's
earnings Abby's earnings and let's let B
equal Ben's earnings Ben's Ben's
earnings then they tell us how these
earnings relate they first tell us that
together they earned $50 so that
statement could be converted in
mathematically into well together that
means the sum of the two earnings so a
plus B needs to be equal to $50 Abby's
Plus Ben's earnings is $50 and then they
tell us Abby earned $10 more than Ben so
we can translate that into Abby is equal
to or Abby's earnings is equal to Ben's
earnings plus 10 Abby earned $10 more
than Ben so we have a system of two
equations and actually with two unknowns
and then they say how much did each earn
how much did each earn so to do that and
they want us to solve this graphically
there's multiple ways to solve it but
we'll do what they asked us to do let me
draw some axes over here and I'll be in
the first quadrant since we're only
we're dealing with earnings so neither
of their earnings can be negative and
let me just define the vertical axis as
Abby's axis or the Abby's earnings axis
and let me define the horizontal axis as
Ben's axis or Ben's earnings axis and
let me just graph each of these
equations and to do that I'm going to
take this first equation and I'm going
to put it in the equivalent of
slope-intercept form it might look a
little unfamiliar to you but it really
is slope-intercept form let me rewrite
it first so we have a plus B is equal to
50 we can subtract B from both sides so
let's subtract B from both sides and
then we get we get a is equal to
negative B plus 50 so if you think about
it this way when B is equal to 0 a is
going to be 50 so we know our we know
our a intercept we could call it we
normally we call that it a y-intercept
but that is the a axis so this right
here let me call this this is 10 20 30
40 and 50 so when if if been made the
zero dollars and a B would have to make
$50 based on that first constraint so we
know that that's a point on the line
right over there and we also know that
the slope is negative one that B is the
independent variable the way I've
written it over here and this
coefficient is negative one or another
way to think about it is if a is zero
then B is going to be 50 if a B made no
money then Ben would have to make $50
and that falls purely out of this
equation right here if AB you made
nothing then Ben would have to make $50
so 10 20 30 40 50 so those are those two
situations and every point in between
will satisfy this first constraint so
let me connect the dots so it would look
something like that that's due to this
first constraint due to the fact that
together
they earned $50 now let's think about
the second one and Abby earned $10 more
than Ben so that's this equation right
here it's really already in our slope
intercept form if Ben made zero dollars
then Abby would make $10 so that's our a
intercept so it's right over there
we could keep doing that our slope is
going to be 1 here if Ben makes $10 then
Abby is going to make $20 if Ben makes
$20 Abby is going to make $30 then makes
we could keep going but I think this
gives us the general direction it
already hints at a point of intersection
so just eyeballing it so we've graphed
the two constraints together they are in
$50 that's the magenta constraint right
over here Abby earned $10 more than Ben
that's this green constraint right over
here and it looks like we have a point
of intersection it looks like we have a
point of intersection at been earning 20
let me label this is 10 20 30 40 and 50
so this is been earning 20
and a be earning this is 10 20 and 30
and a be earning 30 so just eyeballing
it off of this it looks like it looks
like a is 30 and B is 20 and let's go
verify that make sure that that these
levels of earnings for a B and men
actually satisfy both constraints so the
first constraint is that a B plus men
have to make $50 well 30 plus 20 is $50
so it meets our first constraint the
second constraint is that Abby earned
$10 more than Ben that a B is equal to
Ben plus 10 well once again over here
Abby is making $10 more than Ben so it
may it meets our second constraint and
that's we only have two of them
so it meets both of them so that's our
solution a beer into $30 been earned 20